[Musica]
[Applauso]
buon pomeriggio a tutti
allora di cosa parliamo oggi io nella
mia vita viaggiatore avuto l'opportunità
la fortuna di vedere diversi paesi del
mondo è l'ultimo curiosità ter all
83esimo un bel numero né però in realtà
conto anche italia san marino e città
del vaticano quindi sto un po barando
sono stato un po ovunque come mi dicono
anche se in realtà i posti da visitare
che mi mancano sono tanti e soprattutto
i posti che conto sono quelli che ho
visitato quali dove ho messo piede ma
non quelli dove effettivamente vissuto
un'esperienza di viaggio significativa
quale si possono proprio contare sulle
dita di una mano
nel corso degli anni essendo che il
viaggio è la mia passione più grande
assieme alla fotografia ed è anche il
mio mestiere ho deciso di studiare il
modo per migliorare il mio approccio nel
cu nei confronti dei viaggi proprio per
migliorare il tempo che posso all'estero
che passa in giro per il mondo
l'avventura perché comunque il tempo è
una risorsa che nessuno ci ridarà più
indietro e questi viaggi mi portano via
veramente tanto tempo e mi portano
lontano dai miei amici dalla mia
famiglia lontano da casa e quindi mi
impegno per fare in modo che questi
viaggi valgono veramente la pena di
essere vissuta
mi sono reso conto anche pensando la
tematica di queste dax che i viaggi per
me più significativi sono stati quelli
in cui sono andato ad abbattere delle
barriere o soprattutto a superare dei
limiti ma in particolare i limiti che mi
ero ha avuto imposto per esempio io
anche se magari non si direbbe fino a
qualche anno fa non viaggiavo in ostello
io avevo il timore a buttarmi in una
situazione di disagio di mancanza di
privacy magari anche mancanza di
sicurezza viaggiando con attrezzature
importanti a livello anche di costo e a
un certo punto ho capito che le persone
che secondo me questa è una cosa che
penso da sempre sono la la più grande
ricchezza dei viaggi sono le persone più
dei paesaggi più del cibo più della
cultura della storia e dei luoghi in sé
le persone che popolano questi luoghi e
le persone che mi accompagnano in
viaggio li i rapporti che si creano in
viaggio sono sicuramente la ricchezza
più grande
e le persone più interessanti io non le
ho mai trovati in hotel
non l'ho mai trovate nei villaggi
turistici le trovo negli ostelli e
quindi questo il motivo che mi ha
portato a superare quel piccolo limite
del non voler viaggiare in ostello e
andare a buttarmi anche in questa
situazione poi io ancora oggi faccio
fatica quando per esempio prenoto un
alloggio un appartamento in affitto a
prendere una casa che non sia intera
sistemazione privata con check in
automatico perché non voglio neanche
incontrare la persona che viene a darti
le chiavi poi però un certo punto ho
capito che quella persona che viene a
darti le chiavi ci tiene talmente tanto
al successo del tuo soggiorno che è
disposta a darti tutti i consigli
possibili immaginabili che arrivano da
una persona che quel posto lo vive
e quella la sua quotidianità e questo
vale molto di più secondo me di una
semplice guida turistica che ti serve i
luoghi da vedere ristoranti con numeri
di telefono per prenotare su un piatto
d'argento e quindi ho iniziato anche a
entrare in contatto con le persone che
mi ospitano facendomi proprio ospitare
dalle persone del bossi sono appena
stato per la quindicesima volta in
giappone un paese che non mi stanca mai
soprattutto sono una persona che
preferisce tornare nei paesi che ha già
visitato tante volte piuttosto che
andare a cercare un paese nuovo da
grattar via dalla cartina perché sia un
po voglio andare sul sicuro sia voglio
approfondire sedermi meglio i luoghi che
più mi hanno colpito uno di questi al
giappone che rimane il mio paese
preferito al di fuori dell'italia e
durante l'ultimo viaggio siamo stati
ospiti a casa di una famiglia una
famiglia composta da due signori anziani
che non parlavano una parola di inglese
tranne alcune parole che però utilizzano
sempre nel contesto sbagliato e li ho
potuto vivere situazioni di fortissimo
disagio che fino a qualche anno fa avrei
proprio evitato come la peste per
esempio sono andato a casa di queste
persone che avevano tutti gli orari
perfettamente schedulati per lavarsi per
mangiare momento karaoke anche lì io
sono una persona che soffre nel profondo
quando a qualcuno accanto che canta o
quando mi fanno cantare io provo sto
male l'ho dovuto fare superando questi
limiti che mi sono autoimposte perché
non devo andare a casa delle persone che
vogliono ospitarmi perché non devo fare
il karaoke e cantare o sole
con un signore anziano giapponese che ha
deciso di passare la sua pensione nel
sud del giappone
l'ho fatto e ho soltanto bellissimi
ricordi legati a vuole esperienza li per
li c'e tantissimo disagio ma poi una
volta tornato a casa ti rimangono prima
di tutte le cose positive e i momenti di
disagio le scomodità le vedi col sorriso
il viaggio più importante della mia vita
è stato quello del cammino di santiago
che ho fatto omaggio e quello è sulla
carta il viaggio proprio all'insegna del
disagio dove ci sono dei limiti che o li
superi oppure tel aviv veramente male
perché io ho dovuto convivere con
persone che non conoscevo per più di un
mese camminando tutti i giorni anche 30
km al giorno andando a dormire ogni
giorno in una sistemazione diversa
sapendo che avevo ogni cosa come sulle
spalle dovevo camminare per spostarmi
ogni chilometro lo facevo a piedi avevo
piena consapevolezza di cosa aveva nello
zaino e quanto pesava lo zero proprio
perché era sempre con me poi arrivato a
fine tappa dovevo trovare posto in un
ostello spesso lurido magari con una
sola doccia un solo bagno per gli uomini
uno per le donne
o magari uno ogni 50 persone con di
condividere la camerata con anche 75
persone distribuite in letti a castello
dormendo su materassi sfondati coletto
che trema quando quello sotto si muove
c'è quello che scoraggia quello che
russa quello che punta la sveglia alle 5
20 al mattino messa così sembra il
viaggio più terribile che una persona
possa fare però tutti questi disagi e il
limite che mi sono imposto di muovermi
esclusivamente con le mie gambe e
soltanto ascoltando il mio corpo hanno
reso il viaggio per cammino di santiago
il più importante di tutti per me quello
che non finirò mai di consigliare a
chiunque perché tante persone quelle che
viaggiano con me con i viaggi che
organizzo mi dicono quando parlò il
cammino di santiago io non ce la farei
mai non ce la farei mai a condividere lo
spazio con così tanti sconosciuti non ce
la farei mai camminare così tanto poi
vai a fare il cammino e ti rendi conto
che in qualche modo ce la fai
e ci sono arrivato gradualmente perché
prima di fare il cammino di santiago e
non mi sono buttata come un eroe a fare
questa avventura allo sbaraglio in
realtà volevo essere sicuro e primo
fatto la via degli dèi un'altra
esperienza
io tantissimo anche perché ce l'abbiamo
in italia oltre alla valorizzazione del
territorio si tratta di un viaggio
davvero economicissimo si può fare a
piedi tra bologna e firenze
la via delle idee mi ha dato la fiducia
necessaria per buttarmi in questa
situazione che è stato il cammino di
santiago è anche la mia prima esperienza
vera di viaggio che mi ha fatto dire
quello che ho appena vissuto era 2013
quello che ho appena vissuto
è un vero viaggio tutte quelle che ho
vissuto prima erano soltanto delle belle
vacanze che per carità ho fatto delle
belle fotografie messo sui social o
fatti laiche in vide agli amici però io
come penso neanche voi in un viaggio per
motivi social non siamo così
superficiali quello che mi porta a
viaggiare è la ricerca di un'esperienza
di viaggio che mi cambia la vita
e un'esperienza che mi ha veramente
cambiato la vita è stata quella
dell'india nel 2013 io ero già stato in
di nel 2011 per avevo fatto un giro
abbastanza classico avevo fatto nuova
delhi agra jaipur way l'on
e anche in treno e mi ero sentito molto
avventuriero perché era il primo viaggio
che facevo da solo però in realtà era
tutto molto organizzato era tutto molto
turistico non c'è nulla di male io
stesso faccio viaggio organizzato
organizza viaggi organizzati
però quel viaggio mi ha dato la fiducia
necessaria in me stesso per andare a
buttarmi in una situazione di avventura
totale nel 2013 quando per conoscenze
giri strani sono arrivati in andhra
pradesh non so quante persone qui in
sala abbiano mai sentito parlare
dell'andhra pradesh ma è una zona
dell'india che non è molto interessata
dal turismo occidentale
tant'è che nel momento in cui io mi
trovavo lì mi hanno detto probabilmente
sei l'unico occidentale che c'è in tutta
la zona ed essendo un ragazzo giovane
pelle chiara capelli chiari lunghi su un
uomo suscitava anche molta curiosità e
c'era una barriera altissima tra me le
persone che mi circondavano che era
quella linguistica e culturale e quindi
io avevo una paura tremenda di trovarmi
in quella situazione perché provate a
immaginare un ragazzo giovane che ha
fatto pochi viaggi da solo nella sua
vita che si trova in uno stato
sconosciuto dell'india dove nessuno è in
grado di comunicare con te le persone
che mi hanno accolto parlavano anche un
po di italiano
ma nei momenti clou del viaggio quando
magari ho assistito a un esorcismo
conosciuto una divinità sono successe
cose veramente pazze per e nicola del
tempo anche per il nicola di adesso io
ero da solo ed è assurdo sentirsi soli
in un paese come l'india che è un paese
talmente affollata dove la solitudine
non è concepita però c'era questo muro
insormontabile tra me le persone del
posto che mi ha impedito di comunicare
anche annuire lo fanno in maniera
diversa noi muoviamo la testa su e giù
allora la muovono di lato e quindi ero
veramente un alieno però questo essere
alieno mi ha portato ad aprirmi
tantissimo e li ho superato il limite
più importante di tutti per me ed è
quello che ha reso il viaggio così
speciale io sono una persona che magari
non può anche non sembrare ma quando
viaggia è anche una vita reale tende a
permanere nel proprio stato di
solitudine se da solo oppure si apre al
momento in cui è in gruppo in quel
viaggio lì non avevo la possibilità di
aprirmi perché non ero in gruppo l'ho
dovuto fare per forza perché era l'unico
modo per riuscire a vivermi il viaggio
per davvero
dato che ero ospite di persone che non
conoscevo mi basavo tutta la mia
esperienza so la fiducia perché mi hanno
portato a casa di gente a mangiare cose
io non conoscevo niente nessuno aveva
modo di comunicare però questo
oltrepassare il limite è stato ciò che
veramente ha dato una svolta alla mia
vita viaggiatore ed essendo la la
passione per il viaggiare la mia
passione più grande
tutto ciò si traduce anche in una
crescita personale e secondo me quella
della ricchezza più grande che si può
ottenere da un viaggio veramente
veramente bello che valga la pena di
essere vissuto i consigli che mi sento
di dare alle persone che mi seguono le
persone che fisicamente mi seguono nei
viaggi viaggiano con me è quello di fare
dei piccoli passi
durante le varie esperienze che si fanno
all'estero ma anche in italia generale
fuori di casa per non uscire magari
dalla propria conforts una mamma non
mano allargarla per trovarsi meglio in
tante situazioni
io per esempio fino a qualche tempo fa
non concepiva l'idea di semplicemente
dormire per terra e pure quest'estate
quando abbiamo deciso di fare un totale
di credo 60 chilometri a piedi abbiamo
miseria miseramente fallito se poi siamo
andati a fare autostop autostop altra
cosa che in italia non volevo fare
perché avevo paura l'ho fatta andato
tutto bene
meno male e ho dormito per esempio sotto
la rocca d'assisi e quella è una cosa
che è difficile da spiegare perché chi è
che vorrebbe andare in vacanza dopo aver
lavorato tutto l'anno per dormire per
terra all'aperto
eppure io quella volta ho provato e nel
momento in cui la racconto vedo che
suscita tanta invidia perché spiego che
è vero mi sono svegliato nel cuore della
notte per le zanzare e l'umidità e il
freddo però quando aperto gli occhi
sopra di minaccerà la volta celeste che
mi illuminava non c'era l'allarme
antincendio di una stanza d'hotel uguale
a miliardi di altre sono piccole cose
che ti possono veramente cambiare in
modo di viaggiare e migliorare il tuo
approccio ai viaggi viaggiare secondo me
è una cosa bellissima che chiunque
dovrebbe avere l'opportunità di fare non
serve andare in capo al mondo per vivere
delle esperienze bellissime anche perché
io per esempio la via degli dèi o queste
esperienze che ho fatto quest'estate le
potevo vivere anche all'estero ma in
italia o tutte le opportunità che mi
servono i viaggi più belli in un viaggio
più bello permesso del cammino di
santiago che dietro l'angolo e in spagna
non è stata l'avventura che ho vissuto
in polinesia quando per esempio anche lì
aveva una barriera insormontabile con il
pescatore che aveva portato a pescare
che non parlava in inglese né francese
parlerà soltanto la sua lingua e la
parlava pure male e quindi non aveva un
modo di capire nulla però in qualche
modo abbiamo comunicato e ho imparato
più o meno a pescare cosa che poi ho
rifatto anche durante lo scorso viaggio
sono piccoli accorgimenti che veramente
di camere al modo di viaggiare e diventa
più soltanto una bella vacanza diventa
una vera esperienza di viaggio e una
cosa che non mi stancherò mai di
propagandare e il viaggiare leggeri
sembra una banalità ma viaggiare leggeri
e significa viaggiare meglio io quando
viaggio non ho la la trolley o il
trolley
non ho la valigia o sempre lo zaino lo
zaino ti dà la possibilità di essere
pienamente consapevole di cosa ti porti
dietro perché sei tu a viaggiare non le
cose che ti porti con te meno cose ai
nello zaino che siamo ovviamente cose
utile che ti possono servire perché io
domani vado in islanda non ci vado che
pantaloncini corti minimente pantaloni
lunghi però uno zaino fatto con
consapevolezza con poche cose è sinonimo
di viaggiare meglio sembra una cosa di
poco conto ma il primo passo verso un
viaggio che ti permetti lasciare a casa
le comodità e abbracciare tutto ciò che
l'esperienza ti può dare e le cose che
viaggi li possono dare sono veramente
tante ci sono anche dei limiti che mi
sono auto imposto come per esempio
quando ho fatto il cammino ho deciso di
muovermi soltanto a piedi nulla mi
impediva di prendere un taxi il giorno
in cui mi sentivo realmente stanco e
svogliato per rispettare l'itinerario
che poi non ho rispettato perché ero
partito con l'intenzione di non
programmare nulla
quest'estate ho anche fatto un viaggio
in ape car per l'italia sarei potuto
andare con la mia macchina come al
solito sarebbe stato più comodo e più
sicuro però mi sono imposto il limite di
muovermi soltanto quella colata in quel
caso i limiti sono anche funzionali al
viaggio e ti permettono di dare più
valore renderlo più speciale però non
credo che sia necessario secondo me la
cosa più importante è superare i limiti
che noi stessi ci imponiamo volevo
concludere con un piccolo paragone
fotografico perché comunque mi mi occupo
anche di quello che preferisco scattare
in analogico
può sembrare star che comunque facendo
video fotografie pubblicandole sui
social ovviamente utilizzo i miei
strumenti digitali però scattare in
analogico per me significa dare molto
più lavoro valore alle fotografie e
rinunciare a dei mezzi comodi per avere
in cambio un limite che ti auto imponi
che dà una grossa spinta la creatività e
le foto che va da ottenere le mie
creazioni possono non piacere possono
essere tecnicamente perfette di solito
non lo sono
però sicuramente valgono per me è molto
di più allo stesso modo i limiti che ci
si può imporre in viaggio possono dare
molto valore al viaggio anche se credo
che comunque la cosa più importante sia
piano piano espandere la propria zona di
comfort
lasciando a casa le comodità e
abbracciando l'imprevedibile sono in
anticipo di 10 secondi comunque
[Applauso]
grazie mille
beh non so se devo uscire comunque buona
serata a tutti grazie
[Applauso]